To have a good understanding of a file systems, we need
to know how application developers interact with it. There are two
main ways of doing this. One way, keeps track of a
position or cursor in the file, and as we read or
write to the file, we move the cursor around. The other
way allows us to treat a file, as though just a
block of memory. Let's cover the position-based strategy first. We begin
by opening the file, with the open procedure, specifying how we intend
to use it, with some flags. Notice that I'm using the
lower-level system calls, rather than C's built-in procedures like fopen, which
sometimes use an extra layer of buffering. It's not that the
extra layer's a bad idea, I just want to interact more
directly with the operating system. Having opened the file, we can
then call read or write as we wish. Write, I should
say, overwrites instead of inserting, as the cursor does by default
in most editors. And as we read and write, we move
the cursor through the file. If we want to move
the cursor without reading or writing, we use the lseek
command. Which repositions the cursor in the file. And finally
when we're done with the file we should close it,
so that the file system knows we're done. Now I've
skipped over most of the details here, because I thought
it would be a lot more fun for you to
learn them on your own, with a little programming exercise.